[Music]
hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan today I'm
gonna answer a question for one of my
newsletter readers Nathan and it's a
very common question that I get asked a
lot and I love answering it so here we
go it's from Nathan again and he wants
guidance on what the businesses start so
he's hoping to become an entrepreneur
doesn't know how to get started and what
specific type of businesses start and
it's great that you're thinking like
this a lot of entrepreneurs just start
up because they're hoping to make a lot
of money and that's a great goal you
definitely want to make a lot of money
but it's typically the guys who just try
to make money they never end up making
money and you find it the most
successful entrepreneur research fine
you know any any entrepreneur really
respect the famous entrepreneur there's
a lot on our site if you look at how
they got started and why it's because
they had a really strong passion for
whatever they were doing yes they wanted
to make money but they also wanted to
have an impact on the market that they
were going into so when you're first
starting up it's a really exciting
opportunity especially where you are now
because you can pick anything there's
unlimited opportunities so it's finding
the one that best suits you and not just
going after something that you think
will make a lot of money what I found
really helpful when I'm when I'm helping
entrepreneurs and in my book I'm
creating this chart that I think will
help people but I'll try to describe it
for you guys watching the video when
you're trying to pick what idea you
think would be a good opportunity for
you I like coming up with three
different columns so the first one is
what are you really passionate about and
that's what do you like to do you know
when you're not going to your job right
what do you do on your weekends what
would you like to do all day long if you
could and try not to put things like sit
on a beach watch TV you know that stuff
comes out of just having too much work
and being overstressed you couldn't
really watch TV all day long and be
happy you couldn't sit on the beach all
day long and be happy trust me you know
you'll do it for a month and then you'll
get bored and you want to do something
right as people we want we want to be
creative when we want to help people and
have a purpose and it's not going to be
lying on the beach you watch TV so yeah
that stuff might be fine but try to
write down on your list of what you're
passionate about things you can see
yourself doing all day long and be
really excited about it now for me I
love helping entrepreneurs and I love
the world of entrepreneurship and I
could spend all day doing much of
inertia puff and I do spend a lot of my
day
doing and it's never tiring for me it's
always exciting so you want to find
something like that with your own
business
something that you could be always
excited by so start making that list so
hopefully come up with a few ideas you
know maybe go for ten different ideas
the next list I'd make is try to come
with another ideally ten of things that
you are excited about or want to learn
so something you've always wanted to try
to do something that you know maybe you
haven't had the time to do before or you
were just afraid to do it you didn't
believe in yourself you have enough
confidence the things that you you wish
you could do and see if there's maybe a
business opportunity for you somewhere
in there so you know potential passions
things you're not quite sure if you're
super excited about what you want to try
so make that list and then the third
list is things that you've solved the
frustrations for you so look at the
things in your life that caused a lot of
frustration and how did you go about
solving it because a lot of the
entrepreneur that are successful they
started around a paint right so if
you're having a lot of frustration and
you were able to solve it then chances
are there's a lot of other people who
have the same problem and maybe you can
help them solve it and for you maybe
it's really super easy how you did it
but for other people might be really
difficult and so there's an opportunity
there for you to create a product or
service to be able to help them solve
that challenge so make that list of
things again you're really passionate
about things that you want to learn that
you're that excite you that you haven't
really tried too much yet and then
things that you've solved as a
frustration for yourself that you think
might be able to help others once you
have that list I start scoring them and
how its score it is on two factors one
how much does it excite you right how
much how much fun you think it's gonna
be because you're gonna be doing this
it's gonna be tough you know send up a
business isn't easy but it should at
least be exciting and fun so look at the
ideas that you've created on your list
and come up with the ones that you think
would be the most exciting and fun and
you think you could grow and keep doing
and have a lot of energy with the second
thing is how much is it going to help
people at the end of the day the amount
of money that you're gonna make is gonna
come from helping people right the more
you can help people the more men are you
gonna be able to make that's the
foundation of business it comes from
adding a lot of value to people's lives
so think about all those ideas and see
how much can
impact other people and from there you
should have you know a narrowed down
lists of all your ideas and then how
exciting they are and how much to help
people and your top business
opportunities will come from the ones
that you are really excited about and
you can help a lot of people on that
should be where you should start your
business around we're creating a
worksheet around it but hopefully I've
explaining the video in a way that helps
you kind of take that next step it's a
very common problem a lot of
entrepreneurial eat app into what
they're really good at and build a
business around that and just jump into
something because they think they can
make a lot of money and they usually end
up losing money you're spending a lot of
money trying to make money and not
getting to where they want to be and
it's not fun because you're not doing
something that you're really excited
about and passionate about so hopefully
that helps answer your question for you
guys watching if you like the video
please give it a thumbs up below it
makes you want to do more of these for
you and if you have a question about
this video or another question about
your own business feel free to leave it
in the comments below I always read
those and try to respond as many as I
can
so thank you and I'll see you on the
next episode
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]